[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
hey Conan O'Brien here just showing him
a bedroom here's what's going on in my
world so I'm doing this this blog right
now my older brother's computer so I
guess it's a MacBook bro because it's my
brother's okay this first bit is
something I call messin with Hemsworth's
messin with hands Lutz
this is a thing where I take pictures of
Chris and liam hemsworth and I kind of
mess with them a little bit this first
ones called Liam Hemsworth right back
this is Chris Hemsworth right there this
is Liam Hemsworth right there and this
is Chris edy helmsworth right there yeah
if you got any more ideas for messing
with Hemsworth tweet them at me hashtag
haic own him here are some ideas for
messing with Hemsworth I saw this
trailer for the new Supergirl TV show
that looks pretty cool so this next
piece is called have you seen Supergirl
have you seen Supergirl hey has anyone
seen Supergirl
oh let's ask this librarian
hey librarian have you seen Supergirl no
well let me know if she shows up oh hey
I was just talking this really ugly
boring librarian it's great seeing you
Oh weird Supergirl go maybe this ugly
nerd knows Hey ugly nerd tell me where
Supergirl is right
your back okay that was where is
Supergirl right
have you seen Supergirl oh I got the
name wrong
[Laughter]
entourage movie comes out this week so
in celebration this is a new thing I'm
gonna call guys who are pre psyched to
see the new entourage movie guys who are
pretty sight to see the new entourage
movie these two guys are really psyched
this is yeah Jeremy pivens accountant
really happy
and this giant can of Axe body spray
[Applause]
this last things a videoblog classic my
fans love it it's called animals with
emotions animals with emotions this
baboon saw your new I wa I watch him was
like whatever it has my hair someone
just asked this bug who's ready to party
this squirrel was blown away by this
week's episode of Game of Thrones
this gorilla hadn't seen the new episode
of Game of Thrones and the squirrel
totally spoiled it for
this fish is very disturbed after
watching this video yeah nobody's gonna
want eat this cake now we'll be right
back hey Simon Kellan Lutz is here stick
around hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos
please